I can tell you for sure that we don’t have
enough people, partly noticeable in terms of
positions, but Zro mobiles, this does not mean
sending them to the front, it means that
they undergo training and, in principle, have
some basic understanding of
how everything works and Well, they are not afraid
of it Because now  Basically people
are afraid because they don’t understand at all,
they think that they will come and they will
immediately die there, they will
mock them or something like that,
nothing like that. I think that in general
this is the right decision to form a
reserve if it is needed  in advance so that
people undergo full training, our
problem is not only the lack of people, our
main problem is the lack of weapons, if
we were given everything that was promised, then the
results would be Absolute.
I think that we will not have enough, we will
need additional help for
America’s entry into our country.  the
motivation of people is flowing away, so
people now seem to be like people who would be
forced to force
Well, my point
zora will not
help, well, mobilize a bunch of people and
don’t give them a
speech Well,
I don’t dare say that, you
yourself understand that you should be afraid and  scho vuva na
danumu ST skilki meeting and stench stench for a reason
directly to the fact that tse pitannya first for all
people friend tse pitannya justice tse
pitannya back and forth
[music]
Finan
L